[Music]
so one of the guys i've read a lot
lately and i've enjoyed um
and just because i like how he stirs
things up yes uh he's an edgy thinker
and a brilliant mind is jordan peterson
he's got a lot of things going on out
there and uh there's a thing going viral
on tick tock of him talking about uh
working the miserable
job i want to play that clip and um
and then ken have you guys have you
comment on it
say i have a job i hate it's like well
yeah but i'm not dying from it's like
not as bad as it can be so you think
well i can't jump out of this job
because what about all the risk it's
like yeah no kidding you've got to get
your resume in order you got to send it
out then you have to go get interviewed
and maybe you're not any good at that
you have to come up with a story while
you're a good employee what about all
these risks if i go look for a new job
what about the risks for you to stay
with this job you absolutely hate well
let's think that through okay so i have
this dead end job i hate it i'm getting
better where am i going to be in five
years you're going to be just like you
are now except a lot more of what's good
about you is going to be gone and a lot
more of what's terrible is going to be
amplified because it kills your spirit
yeah so it's like you think oh my god
there's a terrible risk in pursuing this
new job it's like yeah there is a
terrible risk there's a terrible risk
and you stand with your job right now
one of the things that's really really
freeing to understand is that you're
screwed no matter what you do ah
[Laughter]
this line's positive yeah i i have while
he's a brilliant mind i take issue with
two things he said there
uh first of all that's just not true
you're not screwed to whatever you do i
mean we've got a thousand people here
that would testify that that not being
true no i mean he's screwed he's saying
you're screwed if you look if you're in
a miserable job and you look for it
you've got the risk of looking uh and
nobody's saying the risk of staying and
both those are either one of those two
options are screwed if yes yeah if you
look out that way but i don't think you
have to i don't think you have to look
at it that way i don't that's my point i
i i don't think that you have to look at
changing jobs as soon as i argue i'd
like to get him on here to argue i'd
love to argue with him as you know i
enjoy a good argument as well uh but
here's my point
it doesn't have to be so risky
risk is basically a acknowledgement of
i'm afraid that something bad is going
to happen or there is a height
probability you don't have to
have a job that's my point number one if
you move to something that a you
actually are qualified for and you have
a high probability of doing a good job
and you have good character guess what
and the people that you're working for
are good and they're not jerks
the work they're doing is good that's
right and honorable so now the
probability of it working out is
skyrocketed and that's the reality
that's why you get tired for that job
before you quit your other one that's
the other thing i don't know how where
the risk is that's my whole point what's
the risk your life's going to get better
low technically not you're screwed
either way let me that's right let me
tell you what the risk is in not
pursuing work that you actually are good
at
talent that you actually love which is
passion and that actually you connect to
the results of the work that's mission
here's the risk dave that you get to the
end of your life
and you are full of regret because you
never pursued that contribution that
somewhere in your heart somewhere along
the way you knew you desire to make in
fact now delineating people can now
delineate for me the difference between
i hate my job and it's sucking the
marrow out of my bones
and
i just discovered this is like work and
it's not always perfect yeah a big
difference because i i also run into
people on the other in the spectrum who
uh quit at the drop of a hat right the
first time they encounter any kind of
obstacle like someone for the first time
telling them they're not beautiful
pretty and smart
and oh my god their little feelings and
they're gone well you just identified
that's really good but i just no well
i'll tell you you've identified what's
going on is that they've been
psychologically shaken and here's where
it comes from
work well by a phrase that we've adopted
as truth and we've all heard this
uttered before i don't even know who
came up with it
but it's if you love what you do you'll
never work a day in your life that's a
bunch of hogwash i've said it well
that's
it's garbage let me tell you why you and
i work our butts off we do love what we
do we have hard long days here sometimes
really hard days and some days suck some
days do suck this idea some seasons and
some seasons in a calling yes sir will
suck yeah that's what and don't confuse
that with you know because if you have
the expectation
snowflake that every day is going to be
easy and you get a trophy at the end of
every day and you ate gummy bears with
john delony at the end of every session
right you know if you get this if you if
this is your view on life you're about
to get disappointed puppy you will spend
your entire life wandering yeah like a
tumbleweed through the old western
movies that's different than stay in the
job no matter what for 22 years and you
hate it every moment that's unnecessary
suffering that that's those are two
different things yeah you are settling
in that case you are settling for
uh mediocre or you are settling for
below average or you are settling for
suck so let me tell you uh jim collins
talks about this he and i were having a
discussion about it in person not long
ago
the and he talks about in the last book
uh great by choice
he said people are not
afraid
of
something
that uh uh is a stated
that they're not afraid of real problems
most of the time but ambivalence yes not
knowing it scares people to death yeah
and so sitting in your job not knowing
what peterson was talking about yeah
that those two kinds of things not
knowing causes you to not move that
scares people to death yes so the way
you get past the not knowing is you go
through your seven steps it's the seven
stages in the book from paycheck to
purpose get clear stage one why is
clarity so important you just addressed
it what collins is saying is ambivalence
will kill you when we it's it's like
driving into deep fog uh or a heavy rain
to where you can't see past the hood of
your car that is terrifying we
immediately pump the brakes we pull over
the side of the road it's the same
psychological feeling when someone goes
i don't know what my future is i don't
know how i get there i mean that's a
real problem and so it is a paralyzing
uh factor when we go i don't know so why
is get clear so important when i'm clear
on all the different things i can do
even if one of the options is painful
as long as i'm clear that's better than
not knowing well if you show somebody
well let's look at let's look at the
context of the ramsay show for decades
we've celebrated people and we will
celebrate today people that have gotten
debt free when you showed them a clear
path via the baby steps they knew how
stinking hard it was going to be they
went to the first couple classes of
financial peace university were like are
you kidding me this dude that's yelling
me yelling at me on the screen i got to
do that they know it's going to be hard
but they still do it why because they
see on the other side of it they see
freedom from debt
seems pleasant at the time but it yields
a harvest of righteousness when we see
it we can do it when we see a desired
future we will endure pain so i and so
completely agree with uh that was a
50-second clip i completely agree with
47 seconds of petersburg yeah absolutely
but you're screwed either way i don't
agree with it i don't agree with that
either it's classical it's a great line
classic peterson but you're not you are
screwed either way if you freeze
yeah and if you accept the fact you
accept the fact that risk is the only
way to get out that's right you can you
can limit the risk by following a very
clear path and a clear process for
landing the other position that is
better pay but more importantly a better
environment with a better upside that's
right better people and a better product
than you're doing now and you can leave
the dumpy job
with class with class and never you've
given it a fair shot yes and know that
when you went into it here it is the
seven stages are get clear i know what i
want to do why i want to do it then i
got to get qualified that's the ticket
to the dance i got to get connected dave
because that's where opportunities come
to me i'm not beating doors down then
i'm going to get the opportunity to get
started now i'm focused on getting
promoted climbing up i would eventually
get that dream job and then i'm working
like no one else to give myself away
i've made gobs of money experienced
tremendous meaning now it's about
leaving a legacy those are the seven
stages in the book from paycheck to
purpose and they work by the way nothing
risky about those